welcome back to las vegas now mexican
independence day is coming in september
and we are giving you a head start on
all the caliente ways to celebrate at
the grand canal shops at the venetian so
let's welcome singer songwriter eli
zamora and entertainment manager tori
ishida to the show for all the details
welcome guys thank you thank you so much
oh gosh i can't wait to tell everybody
about this okay september 16th is the
actual independence day but before we
get there let's talk about you eli tell
us a little bit about your you know
music career so music really runs into
my family and my dad started singing she
was a christian artist and then we were
grew up in choir they went to school i
went to bird clutch and music and
everything in his college over there
then after that i did the voice mexico
then after that i did the voice usa when
i was team kelly clarkson
so um i've been i've been doing you know
a lot of performances like that and i'm
just trying to get my name out there and
just working songwriting and performing
it where i can uh because music is my
life it's what i do so i don't see
myself doing anything else so i'm very
happy to be here right now well
congratulations you are a headliner
again for the mexican independence day
celebrations at the venetian so let's
just talk about you know why it is the
ultimate place to celebrate to me means
everything just because i grew up in a
bicultural i grew up in el paso texas
which is the front um what's it called
from mexico so it's
in el paso and for me representing both
being like the selena of now yeah
you know like salinas said you're not
from here you're not from over there but
representing them having your roots in
the place that you live yeah to me means
the world and i'm happy to share this to
sing all these ranchera songs heartfelt
songs that really like focuses on
bringing people together and bringing
the community together and really
emphasizing why we're so proud to be
mexican absolutely and las vegas is the
perfect place it's such a melting pot so
everybody can learn and enjoy your
culture um tori let's talk about you
know what else we can enjoy at the
venetian during this time this is how
you eat
i know exactly
[Laughter]
well eli will also be joined by kelly
castro who is also on the bus
um and then we have a lot of great other
wonderful things that are happening um
we have over 160 tenants a lot of our
tenants like um salvatore ferragamo and
tory burch they're doing special things
so everybody come out and check that
those out for them perfect perfect and
just last but not least you know again
it's on september 16th but you're
celebrating
september wide
september wide so september wide you can
come down check out eli on stage where
exactly is the stage so we're going to
be at st mark square september 16 to the
19th at 4 30 p.m so hope you guys see
you there we'll celebrate thank you guys
so much and happy early independence day
nice place
mexican independence day at the venetian
resort september 15th through the 19th 4
30 p.m in st mark square again at the
grand canal shops grand canal shops.com
for more information